[Música]
porque sou quem eu sou seja parar pra
pensar nisso a na grécia antiga
no bloco do tempo de delfes estava
escrito que note se ao tom conhece te a
ti mesmo
mas quem é você
como que você tem sido essa pessoa vida
inteira fez nem se questionar isso eu
poderia dizer eu sou mas quando você era
criança seu corpo era completamente
diferente muito menor por posições
completamente diferentes e você cresceu
e continua achando mesmo são os tecidos
se renovam constantemente suas células
vermelhas do sangue só durou 120 dias e
você continua a achar que você é o mesmo
então de onde que vem essa continuidade
do ser
na verdade na grécia antigamente antes
de cristo plutarco já usava fazer essa
pergunta e usando como modelo um navio
que tinha sido teceu um herói grego foi
preservado após a morte de tv e à
madeira foi se degradando e as tábuas
eram substituídas e chegou um ponto e
todas as tábuas do navio de teseu tinham
sido substituído escutava as novas e
plutarco se perguntou
esse ainda é o navio deu essa esse
enigma então essa charada foi discutida
por toda a humanidade com inúmeros
séculos por exemplo jogam ok é filósofo
inglês
um dia vi um furo na sua meia preferida
esse furo então foi remendado e ele
perguntou e se eles foram fazendo
remendos na minha meia e no final não
tenha mais nenhum tecido original da
meia
será que ela ainda vai ser a minha
preferida
então
nós vemos que a continuidade do ser
humano coisa difícil de ser explicada
com base puramente no meu corpo e você
poderia então mudar isso falar não eu
não vou concentrar na parte do coco
mas eu vou olhar isso do ponto de vista
psicológico
eu sou a minha mente eu sou minhas
experiências
eu sou minha memória isso então resolve
esse paradoxo mas por outro lado percebe
bem imaginem se você desenvolveu uma
amnésia
se você desenvolver a doença de
alzheimer você deixa de ser você
se você fizer um transplante de cérebro
e duas pessoas seja o transporte cérebro
você fez um transplante corpo
para complicar a situação o nosso
incorporamos o mundo externo e nós
mesmos
o tempo inteiro nós começamos a vida com
uma célula única com um peso de uma no
grama e nove meses depois nascemos como
bebê com peso de três quilos ou seja um
aumento de mais de 1 trilhão de vezes de
onde que vem essa massa extra que foi
incorporada no bebê
lógico vem da mãe através da nutrição
mas qual quê foi a regra que essa massa
usou para se tornar você então na
verdade todo esse material que vem de
fora tem de seguir as regras de
organização do genoma da pessoa e ali
está escrita na linguagem de do código
genético
as instruções estão escritas as
instruções para que esse material seja
incorporado na pessoa
depois que você nasce você continua a
crescer
incorporando material do mundo exterior
dessa vez usando a sua própria nutrição
e então isso tudo é controlado pelo
genoma que é extremamente individual
na verdade ele é singular em toda a
humanidade
e esse pode ser provado uma maneira
muito simples
há 30 anos atrás nós introduzimos no
brasil o laboratório
o teste de paternidade por dna lutando
as impressões digitais e dna são
mostradas aqui com duas ondas f10 que de
nf-e 24 cada uma dessas colunas
representa o padrão de bandas de uma
pessoa diferente e você vai observar que
então nós temos padrões de bandas
diferentes para cada pessoa
mesmo que sejam como nesse caso membros
da mesma família e nós podemos fazer
raciocínios matemáticos em cima desse
tema
por exemplo se nós calcularmos a
probabilidade de ter dois padrões de
bandas iguais em duas pessoas
você vai ver que isso na humanidade
atual é de cerca de uma em um quintilhão
que é um número muito maior do que a
quantidade de pessoas que existem na
terra ea quantidade de pessoas que
jamais existiram na terra e isso apenas
usando duas ondas de dna e agora olhar
geral como um todo
então você vai concluir todo é tão
variável que nunca no futuro vai haver
ninguém olha você não só a e que na
verdade nós somos o nosso genoma é um
evento único no universo da história de
todo o universo nunca houve nada igual
o senhor shannon o que pode funcionar
nos autos autoestima né
mas então será que nós conseguimos achar
a chave para o nosso ninho será que nós
conseguimos definir o que é que torna
unidade do ser que permite isso
será que é o genoma então a informação
do dna que permite isso
infelizmente não e a resposta de porque
não vem nos gémeos e 19 terrenos
os gêmeos univitelinos ele esteja novas
iguais mas são pessoas diferentes no
caso aqui vocês estão vendo três gênios
que morfologicamente são indistinguíveis
mas um deles desenvolveu e foram isso
foi mostrado no documentário recente a
um deles desenvolveu a psicose bola'
grave e acabou se suicidando
então a existe diferenças mesmo em
gêmeos univitelinos e de onde é que vêm
essas diferenças não vem do genoma que é
idêntico vem do que da sucessão de
ambientes que aquela pessoa vem
experimentando um ambiente pré natal e
os ambientes pós natais que ela vem
experimentando que se incorporam na na
própria fábrica do ser que a gente
continue essa conversa não ter de
introduzir dois novos termos
o primeiro é genético que é um conjunto
de todos os nossos genes o genótipo está
contido no nosso genoma e um outro é
fenótipo que os outros vêem em você
percebe sobre você no fenótipo está
contido no seu próprio erótico é o que
você e então ele está no seu grupo
ele está nas suas formações sináptica e
ele está mesmo nos micro biomas ou seja
as comunidades microorganismos
se ele obviamente vivem na sua pele a
sua boca no seu destino
isso tudo é o seu fenótipo e um fenótipo
ele é determinado e não somente terminou
mas pelo genoma em interação íntima com
o ambiente
mas essa integração não é uma soma de
elite genoma não é dois mais dois é
igual a quatro
você tem sinergismo positivos dois mais
dois é igual a 5 esse legislativos dois
mais dois é igual a 3 e a prova
experimental disso veio na verdade muito
cedo em 1940 um experimento que pouca
gente ouviu falar mas que foi
fundamental
no entendimento dos conceitos genéticos
e então pesquisadores na califórnia
pegaram plantas a mesma planta aquiléia
em cinco cidades diferentes e cresceram
brotos dessa planta que os brotos são na
verdade clones que tem genomas genética
de genótipos idênticos e cresceram em 3
altitudes diferentes e que você vê aqui
em cada atitude o comportamento da
planta é completamente diferente e que
não existe na verdade nenhuma planta que
seja melhor nos três ambientes
então isso é um exemplo com gente da
interação genótipo ambiente na formação
do fenótipo e que a gente também pode
talvez ver isso de uma maneira um
esquema tática metafórica
seria como uma soma de vetores
na soma de vetores você não tem só a
contribuição do genótipo ea contribuição
do ambiente se somando
mas você tem quando entre eles o que é
importante é ter giannotti ambiente e
também a direção dos vetores universo
relativístico que o universo que a gente
vive hoje em dia
é impossível você separar o tempo das
três dimensões do espaço
a espanha foi o primeiro e consciência
disso e criou um conceito matemático que
ele chamou de um contínuo espaço tempo é
uma coisa só
é uma coisa diferente mas é uma coisa só
esse contínuo espaço tempo que existe em
torno do universo e é deformado pela
presença de grandes quantidades de massa
e essa deformação do contínuo espaço
tempo é o que nós chamamos de gravidade
então quando eu vejo a pergunta por que
sou o que eu sou
a resposta que eu gostaria de arriscar é
por causa do meu contínuo genótipo
ambiente
nós somos o que somos porque nós temos
um genótipo que a singular que
exclusivamente nosso e temos também uma
história de vida que é só nossa
esse conceito tem uma série de
aplicações práticas
eu gostaria de se explorar uma das
aplicações práticas num procedimento
está aqui é eticamente bastante
controverso mas que certamente vai vir a
ser feito no futuro da humanidade que é
o desenho de bebês ou seja os designers
e na verdade o que nós estamos falando
aqui é a idéia de você gerar bebês sejam
livres de doenças genéticas e que sejam
enriquecidas naqueles caracteres
positivos como a beleza física
inteligência a capacidade atlét e
capacidade criativa e isso sobrou
imaginário nosso
a partir desse filme chamado de ataque
que foi feito em 1997 mas que é um filme
extrema
atual ainda o que ele lida com questões
a existenciais que são ainda bastante
atuais e há um nome gattaca vem das
quatro letras do dna gerará a crescer e
só agora recentemente os últimos anos
nós passamos a ser capazes de fazer as
modificações fazer as modificações
genéticas que eram feitas nos bebês de
gattaca e e se utilizando uma técnica
que já está ficando famosa em todo mundo
ea chamada técnica dpt para trás
eu não vou ter tempo pra entrar em
detalhes de como essa técnica funcione
mas vale a pena a gente entender que ela
permite de uma maneira bastante simples
você substituir marcinho de dna e fazer
o que a gente chama de edição genômica
então essa técnica é subjacente a todo
um processo de eleição genomas que vão
permitir a construção de beleza e é um
exemplo disso é por exemplo esse artigo
que foi publicado em 2018 que já é um
cargo de direção genômica feita a
experimental mente na china mas em
humanos
isso não pode ser feito é no ocidente
por causa de projetos limitações
técnicas mais na china já é feito
e no caso foi a cura a extração de um
gene alterado a substituição de um gene
alterado causar cenas de marfan a
doenças má fama doença que altera a
formação do esqueleto e das paredes das
artérias e nós temos essa realidade ea
capacidade técnica de
criar bebês que há são com a correção de
defeitos monogênica talvez por enquanto
a gente consiga criar bebês que têm
problemas de poucos deles concordou mas
aquelas coisas verdadeiramente
importantes nós não vamos conseguir
alterar que são o que a inteligência a
capacidade artística é a capacidade
criativa a a a capacidade atlética
porque são múltiplos genes e interação
com o ambiente e nós acabamos de ver que
quando você tem múltiplos genes e
interação com dentes e tem um contínuo
genético ambiente
você não pode prever o fenótipo a partir
do genótipo então a não ser que a
genética mude
nós talvez nunca vamos conseguir
modificar esse caráter se á então por
alguns anos a humanidade ainda vai ter
de viver com gente que tem deficiência e
que superar essas deficiências para
criar obras maravilhosas como musa
assim no egito e na torre ou cromo
tornou o técnico com apenas duas
vitórias ou como van gogh com a psicose
então pra terminar eu vou fazer uma
pergunta pra vocês levarem para casa
beethoven compôs a nona sinfonia aquela
coisa maravilhosa
apesar da surdez ou porque ele era
assunto
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]